all right let's do some housekeeping
here so rick carlisle was ejected during
that
last timeout steven silas will take over
and let's give you the reasons why we
think it happened
hardaway had received the ball when
doc rivers challenged the call rick
carlisle's argument here
to kane fitzgerald was he already has
the ball
he got a t and then carlisle didn't back
off and ultimately
kane fitzgerald takes a few steps back
and sends him out of here so carlisle's
been ejected
kawhi leonard misses the technical foul
shot now to follow
all of that they finally did go to the
challenge
and it was unsuccessful so doc rivers
challenge of that foul by paul george is
unsuccessful
and now there's going to be a free throw
to finish off a three-point play
for tim hardaway so this is the foul in
question chris it is a foul look at that
right arm
right there of george wrapped around the
left arm of hardaway
it had nothing to do with the foul it
had everything to do with the timing of
when the challenge was
allowed by the officials i'm thinking